on est ici à londres au novotel on va
commencer effectivement pour vous parler
de smart proche de commandes dans un
hôtel tout simplement parce que j'ai des
invités dans la chambre d'hôtel
c'est qu'on a derrière sa cantine ou yo
yo et un critérium
il a varié en critérium on a aussi
derrière moi maintenant que tu te lances
sur les vidéos et oui je me trompe
totalement sur les vidéos il évoque ce
raid est on à qui stephen tout créer la
campagne soit 7 steven de sin est
exactement là il perdra son petit voyage
pour honolulu dans quelques instants
il ya d'août exceptionnel tout à l'heure
on prend l'eurostar on prend l'eurostar
pour partir d'un événement de paris
jusqu'à londres et il est assis en face
d'un monsieur mais non mais non merci
et qu'est ce que fait le monsieur
anglais juste en face à steven c'était
bouché et puis le mec avec tous ces
mouchards dégueulasse esterline je faire
pareil vous changez pas vos mouchoirs
sauf que le mec en face il n'y a pas
compris il a pris le mouchoir blanche de
bactéries il serait multedo tendu et
après on ne dira pas ce qu'il a fait
avec ce mouchard tracé voilà on a la
garde
il a gardé donc on n'est pas là pour
parler de mouchoirs à 10 aujourd'hui on
est là pour vous parler de smartphones
de one plus one + 71 ou une plus c'est
éprouvant de plus cet hymne haclave
plein de trucs on dit
[Musique]
vient d'arriver que le lancement là dans
la salle récupérer le petit bateau bien
donc la sage et les courants et en vous
je connaissais pas du tout on a en gros
la deux
rose propose un de la plv nos couches
âge que vous voulez on prend
effectivement de l'écran 90 hier sa
nouvelle puce cell tv sur 27 est trop
comment c'est fait à quoi ça ressemble
en fait à temps les jeunes je vous
montre toi je regarde voilà c'est un
grand hall avec 1
grand écran les normes et cran au dessus
ce qui est juste là il ya beaucoup de
sons on doit avoir probablement une
mclaren là bas parce qu'effectivement un
modèle pâques la reine edition
regardez-moi ça est-ce que là on est pas
mal du tout on a la mclaren edition il
ya un partenariat ça reste quand même
une bagnole à ces jeux incroyables
j'aimerais bien faire un tour bermond à
dix à la vue des vigiles vue grande
sécurité ça va être impossible va faire
un petit tour ici on à la salle où va
avoir lieu
la gombe on passe la sécu alors par là
alors attendez à quoi ça ressemble
histoire aux 330 on trotte très grand
écran je pense pour rediffuser ici on va
qu'on risque d'aller dans les couleurs
un trait rouge plutôt cool comme ça
never sitl balafon on va s'installer le
temps de prendre la température et puis
devant ce que ça dit on s'entraîne on
est juste devant la scène qui est là et
si vous voulez voir des goodies et
surtout est ce que tu as vu le pour le
prompteur qui est juste là avec une
élite
j'ai vu alors c'est la même chose quand
je suis à bfm à 2 g
quand je viens à 2 g ap fmi met deux
prompteurs parce qu'en plus je pour le
droit pour les gauches
oui comme ça c'est la louche it est allé
au sud du compteur soit à la bombe a
coûté super content on est l'affiché
avec toi puis voilà et puis on a le même
âge à dire que je pourrais t'on fils
papa m'a fait jouer vous on est bien on
est bien on est bien 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi tous les modèles quota présenté
aujourd'hui on a celui là le mclaren
edition alors l'idée en fait pas si vous
avez suivi par rapport à ce qu'on a avec
le one + 7 t pro il y en fait c'est un
one + 7 po avec les specs du wan +7 les
pros
mais qui a 12 jan rammeloo savoir
qu'avec le modèle one plus c'est trop et
s'exile monsieur one + 7 pro vous aviez
6,8 carrément bougies viendra sur le one
piece est des pros vous avez uniquement
utile
et là vous arrivez sur la version 12 il
ya drame vous n'avez pas de vent de plus
7 et pro à douce mais vous avez on voit
plus c'est des pros mclaren hicham qui
lui la douce il y en a mais en tout cas
moi je trouve ça pas mal assez mignon
alors que je pense qu'on essaiera de
faire un même beaucoup connaissaient
rien à voir si les conditions sont pas
idéales en termes de son mais en tout
cas le produit est très élégant tout ça
c'est plutôt content
photo mc saint thomas c'est pas un très
grand temps que m ça va c'est mieux que
sony non non moi j'ai un très grand
temps il soutenu
ça va au magasin auchan taxila les boys
qui sortit voir steven est saluée boys
alors aujourd'hui super loulou on va
parler de nouvelle caisse quelques super
et qui est extraordinaire c'est la
casquette de quotas c'est parti jetez
pas de casquette
mais mes jeunes qui commencent à tomber
quoi comme rapide et qui mime du travail
je suis tendu tous âges on est à
tv5monde et sur le stream jeuxvideo.com
voilà alors comme n'importe qui pensent
qu'aux smartphones de modalités du set
alors je pense que je pense que le 7 t
c'est l'un des meilleurs rapports
qualité prix sur le marché parce qu'un
écran 90 cartes
à ce prix là potentiellement moins de
600 euros on n'a pas le plus dur encore
mais ça a l'air plutôt cool
ils ont pris ce qui faisait le sel du
pro du 7 pro ils ont mis dans la version
plus abordable donc je trouve que c'est
trop cool une cep des pros alors le set
est pro il faut avec et dans un
entre-deux un peu bizarre parce que en
fait ils présentent une évolution
minimes
on s'est trop mais avec le même prix et
des quartiers stick augmenté donc est-ce
qu'on peut pas se dire est-ce qui
vampirisent pas est-ce qu'il n'est pas
vampiriser par le 7 t oui je pense un
petit peu donc je pense qu'il a du mal à
trouver sa place et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'il n'est pas disponible dans
certains pays comme par exemple aux
états unis bonjour lutte et kitty bossou
bonjour je m'appelle claire et je bosse
pourri les books je suis rédacteur en
chef volume cela avec qu'est-ce que tu
prends du coup ses smartphones de tous
ses smartphones
je vais suivre l'avis général le one + 7
t c'est à peu près le meilleur rapport
qualité prix
mclaren est très beau mais il faut aller
voir
ce qu'il est en plus oui le 12 il ya 12
giga de ram une jolie coque en alcantara
le cette épreuve on se pose des
questions repositionnement tueur qu'est
ce qu'il vient faire la chaleur tant le
collet qui vous titille alors j'ai beau
chez cnet hockey quand vous aurez une
bonne avance moi tout ça alors on moi le
meilleur téléphone et 3 pourquoi plus
est témoin que cette épreuve a le plus
été pour un quart est pour moi le
meilleur des 3 c loi puisse être
meilleur rapport qualité prix
même par rapport aux 7 pro ouais parce
qu'on retrouve bien entendu toute la
partie photo du 7 pro on retrouve des
spect légèrement améliorée par rapport à
cette gamme l'a donc avec saragosse sur
cinq ans accuse enfin tu feras le résumé
voilà d'accord monsieur et eux c'est
vraiment meilleur rapport qualité prix
parce qu'à côté on accepte et pro qui
propose quasiment la même chose et pour
150 euros de plus ok moi si claire
pleine efficacité mais loin de +7 et
cool
il est joli mais c'est trop et pas mal
aussi mais après faudra voir la vidéo si
elle sera dans la discussion il est bon
c'est très bizarre ce truc saisissez 15
h 20 samedi à wuxi ni aucun vitesse auto
vitesses automatique voilà un petit
massage de pieds ça viens viens copain
vient essayer ça quand j'ai essayé les
massages de tous ces dix ans a atteint
genia votre jean aussi grecques au même
mode jambes mais l'ex ne l'est que je
gémis avec joie aussi et à quoi tu as le
dernier c'est quoi ça elle choque ou ça
fait bizarre
et puis parce que ça te ravage les pieds
en avant je pense que je peux plus
marcher demain avec ça alors par
blizzard c'est très bizarre ce
treichville où je me sens mal à l'aise
mais tu as beaucoup de bonheur comme ont
voyagé j'ai beaucoup de plaisir
sa mort est hyper malin plaisir coupable
j'écoute commune est là quand ce
monsieur n 8 et qui tu travailles août
après comment alors je suis d'avenir
licata je travaille au parisien voilà le
parisien alors tu as pensé quoi ou de
les vaincre journée des produits qui
viennent de présenter par bus
bon là on arrivait sur un format
classique présente évidemment leurs
produits de fin d'année c'est ire nouvel
impôt la gamme
on a l'impression qu'il ya pas eu
forcément de grosses nouveautés on peut
être on a juste fait des ajustements
cost et des retouches mais je suis assez
emballé par un produit en particulier en
fait c'était assez
raisonnable en fait question qui mettait
un peu caché gâcher dans début d'année
qui était disons que lâchés par le 7 pro
voilà en fait cet été c'est plutôt un
rattrapage on a l'impression que c'est
un produit qui vient dire regardez ont
fermé quand même encore capable de faire
des appels schiller et on suit bastien
en fait j'aurais voulu que le 7 soit ce
cet été là avec pour caractéristique et
qui est un petit rattrapage hockey et du
coup le cette pipe pro moins recette est
pro on l'a on est carrément dans la rue
elle touche esthétique
bon c'est quand même un excellent
produit un problème singh convard est de
confondre assez facilement avec le set
[Rires]
est pareil du tout mais bon voilà pour
cet événement one plus c'était très cool
de retour dans la chambre d'hôtel le
temps d'opposer de poser tout ça de tout
mettre d'ordinateurs de dérocher alors
vous font gagner tout de suite c'est
déjà monté c'est déjà fait mais moi tout
de suite au moment où je tourne il me
reste tout à faire des recherches
montrent et 2 3 heures de boulot
il n'est pas hyper tort c'est pas très
grave tout se passera bien j'espère que
ça vous aurez intéressait c'était plus
une vidéo pour vous emmener dans
l'ambiance d'une autre un petit peu le
off les coulisses comment ça se passait
au moment de l'événement
bien évidemment il ya des chaînes le fun
boxing du web + 7 t il ya eu le test
d'une poussette est pro il y aura le
tête du moins de plus c'est et qui va
sortir peut-être celui d'une mclaren
allez savoir en tout cas merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous fais des
gros bisous puis je vous dis à demain
bisous chaos